[Background voices]
AMR MOUSSA >> My name is Amr Moussa. I am
the Secretary General of the League of Arab
States. Here in Davos we are-ah-very busy
discussing the new world. I-ah-listened carefully
to what-ah-Mr. Peres-ah-had to say moments
ago. I agree with his first comment, indeed,
global warming and other issues-ah-new issues-ah-should
be voted before and given the priority in
the-the national corporation and the international
scene.
But for the second point, the-ah-the clerk
that they are going to celebrate the sixtieth
anniversary of the establishment of ______,
I hope that he and his _______ will remember
that this case is also a case of sixty years
of hardship for he Palestinians and that the
time has come for all of us to cooperate to
build a new peace situation in our Middle
East by respecting the rights of the Palestinians
for a state of their own in Jerusalem-East
Jerusalem-as its government. And I hope that
all of us would see an extended Palestine
that were before the end of this year in accordance
with the promises made by Mr. Bush-by President
Bush. I hope that before he leaves, President
Bush will make good on his promise and will
show us that it is possible for this American
administration to produce something that will
be lasting-ah-in its effects on the Middle
East and the world.